donc un détracteur parfois accusé d'être
un opportuniste j'avais c'est une vérité
ma réputation
parce que si j'arrive à vous convaincre
quelques personnes qui regardant cette
vidéo qu'il ya un tout petit lien entre
ce qui s'est passé il ya maintenant huit
jours et le sujet dont je vais vous
parler j'aurais pas complètement perdu
mon temps et je crois que personne ne
seront pas peut-être complètement morte
pour rien c'est avec le début de mon
intervention je vais commencer par
essayer de vous expliquer que ce qu'on
est en train de vivre en ce moment aux
portes sud de l'europe avec le flot de
réfugiés et les attentats dans lesquels
j'espère qu'aucun de vos proches m'ont
laissé nazis qui ont eu lieu il ya eu ce
jour il ya déterminant énergie et climat
peut-être devant pétrole et qui mara qui
est extrêmement fort quand je dis
extrêmement fort c'est un déterminant du
premier renforcée par un truc
anecdotique
je t'ai récipients pour moi intéressant
comme je suis un noob bavard en plus
d'être opportuniste et vous livrer
d'entrée de jeu les conclusions des fois
que j'ai pas le temps de dérouler toutes
les explications
donc je le dis je le redis ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment en
europe n'est pas complètement le fait du
hasard il ya un lien extrêmement fort
avec les questions énergie et climat
par ailleurs ce lien extrêmement fort
qui a notamment déterminer ce qu'on a
appelé le printemps arabe et dont je
vais vous parler détermine aussi et je
vous en parlerai ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler alors qu'au début ça c'est
appeler à une récession après ça s'est
appelée la stagnation séculaire non
c'est en train de siffler la stagnation
millénaire moi j'ai envie de dire que
c'est le passage par un maximum absolu
en ce qui concerne le pib par personne
en europe et pays des vrais au sens
industriel et que falloir faire avec
pour les années qui me reste à vivre et
celles qui vont être à yvon aussi une
autre des conclusions du coup il est
très lié à ce que je vais vous raconter
c'est que ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
le 'business as usual' alger facile vous
connaissez cette expression c'est une
expression très courante dans le monde
économique pour désigner le fait que
rien ne change ce que je vais essayer de
vous expliquer c'est que 'business as
usual' c'est à dire je ne m'occupe pas
du problème c'est pas rien ne change
c'est tout change d'une manière de plus
en plus désagréable c'est ça le business
as usual
à partir de maintenant est du coup plus
le temps passe et plus se renforce cette
der ce dernier élément de conclusion qui
est qu'on a vraiment intérêt à s'occuper
du problème est que moi on s'occupe du
problème et plus pour les autres
produits
on n'est pas en train ce que je vais
vous dire c'est qu'il n'existe pas un
monde économique
à nous de votre vie est une étudiante
allemande etc et puis à côté de ça un
machin qui est dans le journal et puis
c'est un gros coup de mou fais moi peur
intervalles réguliers votre vie
maintenant plus tard et déterminé il
sera de plus en plus déterminé parce que
je vais là déjà été est de plus en plus
parce que je vais vous raconter
j'ai donc commencé un peu par vous
parler de changement climatique puisque
j'ai dit que ça revient un petit lien
mais ce qui était en train de se passer
quand on parle de changement climatique
la quasi totalité des gens ont présent à
l'esprit ce que je suis en train de vous
montrer d'affaires touch ou encore le
réchauffement du reste le dictionnaire
est bien fait c'est qu'il fait plus
chaud il fait plus chaud comme disait
chirac un savant touche une sans faire
bouger l'autre vous avez passé l'été
dernier où il a fait un peu de choses et
bien vivant dans cette salle est bien
vivante dans cette salle il ya eu une
canicule je pensais partir des choses
oreilles mais il ya eu canicule en 2003
il ya quelques vieux con perdu six mois
d'espérance de vie groupes les plus
jeunes dans cette salle s'en foutent ils
ont mérité un peu plus vite
donc tout ça aujourd'hui c'est pas vrai
sujet on voit pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
devrait s'en préoccuper plus que ça
après tout s'il fait chaud et qui a
acheté les climatiseurs
c'est oublier un peu vite que le
changement climatique ce n'est pas qu'un
changement sur les températures c'est un
changement du climat et que le climat
c'est pas juste une température un des
changements majeurs déjà à l'oeuvre
c'est ça que je vais vous expliquer
c'est que quand vous touchez à l'énergie
embarquée dans un système parce que
c'est ça le changement climatique
vous touchez à tous les flux qui
concerne le système et le système
il n'a pas que des échanges directs de
calories il a notamment un autre flux
halle qui est majeur qui soit dit en
passant est un flux de restitution de
l'énergie du sol à l'atmosphère qui est
trois fois plus important que
contact l'échangé de chaleur par contact
qui est la chaleur latente évaporation
condensation ce qu'on appelle le cycle
de vaud je vous rappelle que la terre
est couverte aux deux tiers d'océan donc
nous habitons sur les terres émergées
enfin le général sur ce que navigateur
intrépide mais sinon la terre est
couverte aux deux tiers d'océan et donc
c'est une énorme machine à évaporer et
le changement climatique perturbe au
premier ordre
ce cycle évaporation condensation
quelque chose qui est pas très difficile
à comprendre c'est que sur une terre
plus chaudes globalement vous élaborez
plus et donc vous allez précipité plus
donc le cycle de l'eau globalement
s'intensifier mais cette intensification
pour grand dam de la cgt va se faire de
manière inégalitaire immédiat est ce que
vous montre cette carte que je vous
affiche maintenant c'est les projections
pour le siècle qui vient donc je me mets
dans un siècle et je compare par rapport
à la conduite pour dire les choses de
manière un peu simple sur la variation
des précipitations et or là il ya un
truc évident on va me sauter aux yeux
d'autant plus que la manière dont on
fait les cartes depuis des siècles la
place et le bassin méditerranéen au
centre du monde sait que vous constatez
que le bassin méditerranéen est parti
pour s'assécher c'est déjà pas un
endroit très arrosé les précipitations
moyennes sur le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen son bon an mal an de
l'ordre de la moitié de ce ton enfance
très concentré sur l'hiver l'été il
pleut quasiment pas c'est pour ça que
l'on peut avoir les touristes en tunisie
et vous voyez que c'est déjà pas très
arrosée et il est prévu que ça ça sèche
alors c'est pas la seule zone qui doit
s'assécher il y en a un certain nombre
d'autres qui vont le faire
vous constaterez que ces zones qui
s'assèchent sont globalement située dans
les deux bandes tropicale sud et nord et
sa cellule à la modification de la
conversion à large échelle du ha
qu'on appelle les cellules de vasselay
avec des grands cycles avec de
l'évaporation et des mouvements
ascendants au niveau de l'équateur et
des mouvements subsides ans au niveau
des tropiques qui quand leurs subsides
en arrivant var et l'essec parce que
tokyo s'est évaporée enfin toujours à
condenser au moment où vous avez eu
évaporation audio de l'équateur c'est
pour ça que ici il va plus il va
pleuvoir plus parce que le cycle va
s'accélérer ils à prévoir plus est l'un
de six classes accélérer le mouvement
oui on a exactement le même problème sur
les moyennes en sur les lavandes
tropicale sud notez que l'assèchement
sur ce qu'on pourrait qualifier d'europe
centrale et de sibérie centrale est
quelque chose qui est considéré comme
normal dans le cadre du changement
climatique en cours
mais j'y reviendrai quand je vous
parlerai de l'un des déterminants
conjoncturelle de ce qui s'est passé et
surtout retour du maghreb en 2011
c'est-à-dire une canicule monstrueuse en
russie en 2010 qui a privé une partie
des importateurs de céréales des
céréales importées cette année là j'y
reviens donc ça c'est ce qui est prévu
pour plus tard
alors maintenant on va regarder ce qui
s'est déjà passé voilà une carte qui
vous donne la manière dont les
précipitations ont évolué sur les cinq
dernières décennies dans le monde alors
ça s'est fait à partir de relevés météo
vous avez des pluviomètres dans un
certain nombre d'endroits dans le monde
les relevés météo ne sont pas faits en
fait y'a pas de plusieurs mètres au
milieu de l'océan c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous ne voyez pas de
ailleurs que sur les terres émergées et
vous constatez que là où les
précipitations ont augmenté sur les 50
dernières années c'est en bleu et là où
elles ont diminué ces temps est venu ans
diverses de marne la graduation de cette
affaire c'est dé mm d'eau par décennie
c'est à dire que quand vous avez moins
10 par exemple ça veut dire que à une
décennie d'intervalle les précipitations
annuelles ont diminué de 10 mm sur
l'année il faut savoir que les
précipitations en france je vous le
redis c'est 800 mm par an en moyenne
mais sur les versants exposés à l'ouest
des alpes c'est plutôt 2000 alors que
vous avez les endroits un peu sec ou
c'est plutôt quelques centaines
seulement mais globalement c'est 800
donc là vous voyez quand vous perdez 10
mm sur une décade
ça veut dire qu'en 50 ans vous en avez
perdu 50 donc vous êtes déjà en train de
parler de variations qui sont pas
totalement ridicule au regard des
quantités qui tombe nature et garder ou
ça c'est déjà asséchées et bien on
retrouve notre bassin méditerranéen
mais on retrouve aussi pour vous toutes
les zones sur lesquelles les modèles 10
et ont toujours dit qu'il devait y avoir
de moins en moins de précipitation dans
le cadre d'une augmentation de l'effet
de serre soit dit en passant c'est à ce
genre de signal qu'on reconnaît la
marque de l'effet de serre dans le
changement déjà constatée c'est pas
juste une affaire de soleil donc si
monsieur courtillot avez raison il
serait un foutu d'expliquer
indépendamment du fait qu'il fait des
erreurs d'un facteur 4 sur la surface
d'une sphère on serait un foutu et nancy
authentique on sort est infoutue
d'expliquer ce genre de structures
spatiales sur l'évolution des
précipitations qui ne pourraient pas
être provoqué simplement par une
augmentation de l'insolation
une précipitation je voulais dit tout à
l'heure sur passer en méditerranée ont
lieu essentiellement en hiver
l'insolation a essentiellement en été
donc si c'est juste l'insolation qu'il
provoque l'élévation de température ça
ne vous explique pas pourquoi c'est
surtout en hiver que vous constatez la
différence sur ty colo s'est arrêté vous
voyez que vous avez ce mouvement du
changement climatique déjà à l'oeuvre
sur le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
mais également par ailleurs vous êtes
soit dans soit prêt
certains nombre d'exportateurs
historique de céréales l'australie du
sud il en trouver une à sourire exporte
des céréales la russie et l'ukraine
exporte des céréales dont l'assassin
cherche pas trop pour le moment
le l'alezan n'exporte pas beaucoup la
méditerranée à nice porte à beaucoup non
plus le sahel pas vraiment par contre le
la partie sud des états unis la corn
belt ça oui l'argentine aussi ici il en
mettra pas beaucoup mais vous avez quand
même des zones là dedans qui sont des
exportateurs de céréales
ceci a aussi un lien avec cela alors si
je prends le cas particulier du bassin
méditerranéen
voilà comment ont évolué les
précipitations d'hiver depuis un siècle
en gros et vous constatez sur la
deuxième moitié du xxème siècle la
première moitié une tendance très nette
encore une fois une variabilité
naturelle du climat tendance très nette
à la diminution des précipitations qui
est la marque déjà d'un début de
changement climatique cet abaissement
des précipitations va vous introduire un
facteur limitant dans la croissance des
végétaux
vous avez deux facteurs limitants dans
la croissance des végétaux j'en avais
trois mêmes vous avez la température
vous avez des précipitations et vous
avez la teneur en co2 c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait faire pousser des tomates
rapidement chez les mormons vous les
mettez sous serre histoire d'avoir une
température qui est toujours optimale
vous aurez choisi l'atmosphère en co2 ce
qu'ils font avec du gaz et à ce moment
et vous les arroser à qui mieux mieux et
à ce moment vous avez les tomates qui
pousse très vite parfaitement à ces pics
de temps passant
mais en tout cas est positif et donc
vous avez ici l'application d'un facteur
les victor ans qui va commencer à
s'exercer à plein sur le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen à savoir la
pluviométrie
du coup vous avez ça alors ça concerne
la syrie je vous ai pas montré toutes
les courbes pour tous les pays mais vous
une résonance extrapole assez facilement
la population syrienne depuis 1960 est
passé de 5 à 22 23 millions d'habitants
alors fortement augmenté vous voyez que
dans le même temps la production
céréalière du pays a également fait
significativement augmenté alors avec
évidemment annuel mais la colle à la
population alors là je soit dit en
passant vous avez déjà un premier effet
de l'énergie abondante puisque c'est
grâce à l'énergie abondante on a pu
mécaniser l'agriculture et fournir à
vitesse accélérée des engrais azotés qui
sont fabriqués à partir de gaz la boîte
naturelles ces femmes une énergie
fossile et de des phosphates et de la
potasse qui sont le résultat d'une
industrie minière qui elle aussi voit sa
productivité augmenter quand vous avez
des pelleteuses et des excuses qui
peuvent fonctionner avec du diesel pour
remplacer les gens avec des pelles et
pioches donc l'augmentation de la
productivité agricole dans le monde
en règle générale par un conseil en
règle générale doit beaucoup à l'arrivée
des combustibles fossiles comme
auxiliaire des agriculteurs ce qui a
permis d'augmenter de même à très
significative la production à la fois
rapportée à l'hectare est rapportée à
l'individu qui travaillent remporté à
l'individu qui travaillent soit dit en
passant il a augmenté encore plus qu'à
remporter l'état mais à un moment ça
suffit plus et vous voyez ici un
décrochage très net
au milieu des années 2000 en syrie
qu'est ce que ça signifie
comme les gens sont toujours là sinon la
population des serait en même temps donc
les familles ne sont pas là sinon les
gens mon rêve
ici les familles ne sont pas là alors
que
vision baisse c'est que la syrie trouve
les moyens d'importer ce qui lui fait
défaut alors ses importations
pendant très longtemps n'ont pas eu lieu
en syrie 1 la série s'est auto
suffisante sur le penser verrier partir
de 2007 elle a besoin d'importer
or il se trouve
mauvaise nouvelle pour la série que
c'est à partir de 2016 que le prix des
aliments seraient globalement à
augmenter dans le monde
à la suite de deux effets qui vont se
cumuler
le premier effet c'est que vous avez eu
de tout temps une indexation du prix des
céréales sur le prix du pétrole
vous voyez ici très bien
l'augmentation des prix des aliments
dans des premiers chocs pétroliers puis
ça redescend c'est stable et au moment
du choc qu'on a connu entre 2000 et 2008
oui le prix intérieurs remonter ça n'est
pas juste un effet inflationniste dû au
fait que vous avez besoin d'être du
diesel dans un facteur si vous faites le
calcul de cette manière ça boucle pas
d'accord c'est à dire que la part du
carburant qui va dans le tracteur dans
le coût de production d'une tonne de
céréales ne vous explique pas pourquoi
quand le prix du pétrole double vous
avez le prix des céréales qui augmentent
de 60 à 80 % d'accord ça ne boucle pas
ça vous explique 10 ou 20% de la hausse
note à 80 ce que je vous explique
pourquoi sa boucle sarah ça remonte à la
même vitesse c'est que le marché mondial
des céréales est opéré par des gens qui
d'une manière générale opère surtout
t'as pas de commodités pas seulement les
céréales le minerai fer le minerai de
cuivre le pétrole
le ceci le cela et ils font ça avec de
l'argent d'investisseurs qui eux sont
complètement neutre sur la commodité
dans laquelle il investit
dit autrement le titre qui place son
argent qu'ils investissent dans du
pétrole des céréales il s'en contrefout
et à partir du moment où vous avez une
commodité qui commet un parti part de
mon appartement où le pétrole commence à
monter le jeu d'allocation des actifs
fait que à peu près toutes les autres se
mettent à monter et inversement quand le
pétrole baisse à peu près toutes les
autres se mettent à taper c'est donc en
ce moment le prix des céréales baisse
parce que pétrole baissent mais vous
avez aussi vu que toutes les matières
premières d'une manière
générale baisse aussi un effet d'appel
qui joue mais il ya aussi cet effet là
que cet effet que je viens d'expliquer
qu'il faut donc au moment où la syrie se
met à devoir importer des céréales papou
pour elle le prix des céréales augmente
vous allez dire à quel problème est là
car augmenter ses exportations
oui mais l'essentiel des exportations de
la syrie et c'est là qu'on va retrouver
notre pétrole c'est du pétrole ont
encore la syrie et pour l'essentiel un
exportateur de matières premières alors
les bonnes années quand elle était en
excédent de production céréalière vous
voyez quand vous êtes plutôt vicieux
plutôt ici à l'export théologie à toutes
céréales mais globalement l'essentiel
des exportations syriennes
c'est du pétrole or ce que vous voyez
très clairement sur ce graphique c'est
que la syrie est passé par son maximum
de production de pétrole en 2002 et je
vous expliquerai n'ont pas longtemps du
tout que le maximum de production de
pétrole dans un pays donné est un objet
qui est mathématiquement certains corps
ne pouvait pas y échapper au fait que
dans une zone pétrolière et soit dit en
passant pour la terre dans son ensemble
vous aurez vous avez déjà vu servant des
zones un maximum à l'extraction annuelle
de pétrole
la syrie l'a connu en 2002 vous voyez
2002 c'est un peu avant le déclenchement
des troubles
donc on peut pas dire que c'est à esch
qui a provoqué la chute
là je ne serais pas aussi affirmatif
par contre là je le suis donc vous avez
un pays qui doit faire face à des prix
alimentaires qui augmente qui a des
recettes budgétaires pour financer au
subventionner la hausse des aliments qui
baisse et il s'est passé en syrie ce qui
s'est passé en france en 1789 les gens
descendent dans la rue parce qu'ils ont
faim ils vous verrez un petit peu plus
tard j'ai commencé après affaire
j'aime échapper temporairement du
moyen-orient enfin du proche-orient plus
exactement pour aller sur des propos un
peu plus large
mais quand je reviendrai à l'algérie au
maroc à la tunisie etc
vous verrez qu'on va retrouver ce
premier déterminant du changement
climatique qui ont contraint la
production locale ce deuxième
déterminant du recours aux exportations
avec une explosion des prix des aliments
importés et un troisième déterminant qui
est que pour des raisons énergétiques
lassé des exportations de pétrole
ailleurs vous allez voir c'est autre
chose vont vous supprimez des recettes à
l'exportation et donc vous provoqué une
multiplication par deux du budget
alimentaire pour la moitié de la
population alors même que ce budget
alimentaire pour cette moitié
représentait déjà la moitié ce que les
gens gagnent et donc quand la population
parce que vous êtes ici gras et bien
nourris comme moi donc si l'alimentation
pour vous passe de 5 à 10% le 10 à 20 %
de ce que vous gagnez ça va très bien il
y avait un peu moins de cinéma et vous
envoyez un peu moins de sms vous avez
amplement en vacances quand ce que vous
avez probablement du mal à vous figurer
dans cette salle ou moins compris parce
que ça vous concerne pas l'alimentation
représente la moitié ou les deux tiers
de ce que vous gagnez tout ce prix-là
double vous n'êtes pas en train de vous
dire où est ce que je ne vais pas partir
en vacances
comprenez les armes descendez dans la
rue c'est très exactement ce qui s'est
passé au maroc peut pas au maroc en
tunisie et en algérie en en tunisie en
egypte et je vous dirai pourquoi ça
n'est pas arrivé en algérie au look mais
avant je vais élargir le propos et vous
dire en quoi
le pétrole dans son ensemble a aussi
concerné le printemps un ça je vais
faire un petit rappel le match puisque
après je vais m'intéresser au pétrole
dans le monde
la durée de constitution des stocks de
pétrole de charbon et de gaz que nous
avons sur terre le temps caractéristique
c'est la dizaine la centaine de millions
d'années
vous avez sur terre des stocks de
charbon
le charbon a été formé à l'ère du
charbon exactement il vient de végétaux
qui ont poussé à l'ère du charbon le
carbonifère des espèces de grandes
fougères qui entraient ont sédimenté et
ont donné un résidu qui s'appelle le
charme tant caractéristiques de
formation 300 millions d'années donc le
charbon c'est un fait non renouvelable
si vous attendez 300 millions d'années
sinon pareil le pétrole et le gaz sont
des restes des sédimenter de plancton et
dali microban et le temps que les algues
vives ça c'est pas très long qu'elle
meurt c'est pas très bons non plus mais
que les restes organiques qui vont
précipiter sur le plancher océanique
près des continents parce qu'ensuite il
faut qu'en fuir sa sous les sédiments
avec les apports alluvionnaires des
rivières c'est bien et que la tectonique
des plaques ou colza dans les tréfonds
de la terre que ça vous cuisse tout ça à
petit feu ça veut dire les actifs eux
que ça vous excuse du gaz et du pétrole
qui viennent ensuite se loger dans les
pièges c'est à dire les roches poreuses
situé au dessus de la roche mère il faut
compter de 50 à 100 millions d'années
donc c'est pareil le pétrole s'est
parfaitement renouvelables le gaz aussi
si vous avez 50 à 100 millions d'années
devant si vous ne les avez pas c'est par
maman renouvelables comme vous a priori
vous ne les avez pas et moi non plus
vous allez vivre quelques décennies si
tout va bien et que l'humanité en
collector historique de l'humanité c'est
maintenant de trois mille ans on va
encore durer quelques milliers d'années
si tout va bien et bien à l'échelle des
temps historiques
vous avez des stocks de départ en
pétrole en gaz et en charbon que vous
pouvez considérer comme prescrit c'est à
dire fixer une fois pour toutes d'accord
sont fixé une fois pour toutes
ni stock
dit autrement la quantité totale de ce
que je vais pouvoir faire sortir de
terre
si longtemps en première approximation
entre moins l'infini et plus l'infini à
une borne supérieure encore quantité
filles dans ce temps à partir du moment
où j'ai eu une quantité donnée une fois
pour toutes deux camps de choses
extractible du sous sol
je ne peux pas et ça se démonte
mathématiquement très simplement
extraire cette ressource en quantité
indéfiniment croissante du sol je ne
peux pas chaque année que dieu fait
extraire un peu plus que l'année
précédente
je ne peux même pas extraire chaque
année la même quantité et ce advitam
eternam est d'accord
impossible la seule chose que les mecs
m'autorise en pareil cas c'est que ma
fonction d'extraction sera nul qui
normand suffisamment loin dans le temps
nulle si je vais suffisamment loin dans
le temps et entre les deux passera par
un maximum absolu qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le pic et si je raisonne en
termes strictement mathématique
l'intégrale de la fonction d'extraction
c'était mon extraction cumulé sur la
période est au plus égal aux stocks
extractives de départ c'est justement
parce que j'ai cette condition limite
qui est que mon stock extractible est au
plus égal en parlant que mon extraction
cumulée d'au plus égale aux statistiques
de départ que je suis capable de
démontrer que c'est nul à moins-16 10
nuls à plus et que ça passe par un
accident de celui entre les deux qui
s'appelle ce que je viens de dire soit
dit en passant et extrapolable ou
applicable plus exactement à n'importe
quelle ressource pour lesquelles vous
avez un stock de départ donné une fois
pour toutes
donc sauf à ce que les entrailles de la
terre vous transmute à vitesse accélérée
du silicium en fer ou du silicium en
cuivre ce qui n'est pas le cas
eh bien vous avez vous aurez un pic à
l'extraction annuelle de minerai de
cuivre devinerait d'argent de minerai
d'or de minerai de chrome dominer de
tantale de minerai de vanadium de
bauxite etc etc
vous prenez tous les éléments du tableau
des leiv qui nous intéresse et qui sont
présents sous terre c'est un objet qui
se démontre mathématiquement vous aurez
un pic à l'extraction annuel de ces
minerais le pic d'extraction annuel
d'argent ou d'or je sais jamais est
probablement déjà passé celui de pétrole
il est en cours vous savez que quand on
arrive aux pics à céder matt la dérive
et s'annule tant qu'on n'y est pas
l'extraction crois donc la dérive et est
positive et quand vous arrivez au pic la
dérive et s'annule alors les bonnes
manières croyait manière de savoir si on
en est loin ou pas est de savoir à quoi
ressemble la dérive et sur un siècle et
demi vous avez ici la réponse quand vous
avez une approximation de la dérive et
vous avez le taux de croissance annuel
moyen de la production mondiale de
pétrole depuis un siècle et demi
alors en fait c'est pas la preuve d'un
frein la variation annuelle
c'est une moyenne glissante sur dix ans
parce que au tout début de l'histoire du
pétrole les variations annuelles étaient
tellement en manque que ça vous masque
ça vous fait une échelle qui rend la fin
de la combinaison vous voyez qu'il ya un
siècle et demi avec des moyens
d'extraction extrêmement rudimentaire
soit dit en passant quatre planches et
un coup de pioche on arrivait à faire
croître la production de pétrole de 15%
par an petit aparté je crois qu'il ya un
théorème de match suis pas sûr il ya un
théorème de maths qui dit que quand vous
partez de zéro et que vous vous attaquez
à l'extraction d'une nouvelle ressource
vous avez au début une courbe qui
ressemble à une exponentielle avec un
taux de croissance annuel très fort donc
n'extrapole et jamais les taux de
croissance annuels moyens qu'on constate
aujourd'hui sur le solaire l'éolien ou
la vente de trombone nous lisons et pas
pendant un siècle
j'avais donc mais j'en reviens voyez au
pétrole pourtant c'est facile à extraire
le pétrole 1,2 comparé à l'automne au
bout de quelques décennies malgré une
sophistication des moyens d'extraction
eh bien on tombe à 10 % de croissance
par an au bout de quelques décennies
supplémentaires
malgré une encore plus grande
sophistication des moyens d'extraction
on tombe à 5 et aujourd'hui malgré la
déco
à retenir à culoz du shale oil qui en
fait un retour aux sources c'est après
2,0 pourquoi juste un retour aux sources
de schieren je sais lol c'est dieu de
ceux du pétrole et du gaz de roche mère
donc c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est là où la tête là où la
géothermie par le jeu de l'enfouissement
des sédiments riches en matière
organique a cuit la matière organique et
en a fait du pétrole et du gaz il ya un
certain nombre de cas de figure où ce
pétrole et de gaz ne se sont pas
échappés de la roche-mère où ils ont été
formés
mais s'il s'en sont pas échappés 1 c'est
que la roche et f1 perméable et 2c qui
sont restés diffus dans la roche parce
que au moment où le sédiment forme du
pétrole et du gaz
c'est des petites occlusion et de
l'inclusion part d'audience et plus
grave les petites inclusion de matières
organiques qui forment ce fait trolls et
se garde donc ses 10 fut donc c'est pas
commode à collecter l'eau shale gas est
connu aux états unis depuis deux siècles
c'est en 1824 au 26 que on a mis en
service je sais jamais parce que je
confonds toujours avec la découverte de
l'effet de serre par foyer c'est en 1824
pour 26 que fredonia petite ville de la
côte est des états unis met en service
un système d'éclairage au gaz de ville
rudimentaire le gaz de ville en question
est celle gas qui vient d'un gisement
voisin donc le shale gas c'est back to
the future
c'est quelque chose qui est connu aux
états unis depuis deux siècles
la raison pour laquelle on n'y a pas
touché jusqu'à maintenant c'est que le
gars dit conventionnel est beaucoup plus
facile à extraire
donc tant qu'on n'a pas besoin d'aller
taper dans un truc qui s'exploitent mal
comme le che gaz on n'y va pas ce que
vous avez ici en fait c'est pas vraiment
le taux de croissance de la production
de pétrole c'est le taux de croissance
de la production de liquides à une
petite différence entre les deux voilà
la dict production de liquides dans le
monde cette fois ci depuis un siècle
qu'est ce que vous avez dans les
liquides dans la nomenclature actuelle
de l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
et bien vous avez du vrai pétrole c'est
à dire que vous avez des choses qui
sortent sous forme liquide ou qui
après traitement sont liquides les extra
lourd et l'état sens et vous pouvez
enfourner ça dans une raffinerie et en
produire des carburants dont soit dit en
passant
30% de ce qu'on appelle des middle
distillats et donc du diesel dont
n'imaginais pas qu'on va se passer de
diesel le diesel et le kérosène c'est 30
% de ce qui sort du graphisme donc sauf
à décider que instantanément la
consommation de pétrole dans le monde
ait diminué de 30% les ailes il faut
vous en fassiez quelque chose
donc si vous en voulez pas vous c'est
les voisins qui prendront pour faire
avancer les paiements
donc vous avez ici ce qui sort du lait
liquide mais vous voyez que ce qui
permet d'avoir une courbe duo qu'ils
soient fortement croissante
c'est autre chose que tu t'es tremble et
notamment quelque chose qui est un
résidu de distillation par le froid qui
s'appelle les liquides de viande et qui
en termes chimiques puisqu'on est dans
une école qui s'occupe de chimie ça
devrait vous parlez s'est éteint de
propane butane
c'est à dire c2 c3 c4 c-26 c'est trop
ensuite ces 4 h 10 ça ne fait pas des
carburants ça fait des réchauds à gaz
très simple de partir en camping
ça fait de la matière première très
sympathique pour faire du plastique
c'est la raison pour laquelle le ch et
le gaz qui contient pas mal d thann
un baume à l'industrie pétrochimique aux
états unis ça ne me fait pas plus
marquants par contre ça fait un recours
qui croient donc on se dit qu'il ya ça
c'est plutôt sympa sauf que ça à masquer
le problème
alors pourquoi est ce qu on appelle ça
des liquides de gaz parce que quand vous
séparer le gas gas c'est à dire le
méthane les autres molécules qui sont
associés et thann propane/butane
toussaint sortant avec le gars est
évidemment un vous faites une
destination par le froid et comme le
métal pardon comme le méthane liquéfie à
une température inférieure aux molécules
plus lourdes et bien quand vous amenez
aux bons points cryogénique vous avez
liquéfié tout sauf le métal et ses
produits vous avez liquéfié vous les
évacués de manière séparée et ça
s'appelle des liquides de gaz à cause de
ça ça n'est pas liquide à température et
pression ambiante qui n'est pas liquide
dont vous en faites pas des carburants
encore une fois vous en faites des
réchauds à gaz si ça vous a vu ce n'est
pas des cartes donc vous faites par
avance et les camions les voitures et
les avions et les bateaux avec à-propos
mettez ça dans les statistiques de
production disant tu vas bien la
deuxième chose que vous sortez avec le
gaz ça fait des condensats on doit
rappeler des essences naturelles et en
génie croient que parce que c'est des
essences sauf nous et ça ça s'appelle
des condensats parce que c'est liquide à
température et pression ambiante il ça
qu'on danse en tête depuis c'est à dire
que quand vous sortez le gaz qui
contient un sous forme de vapeur à ce
moment là parce que le gaz il être sous
forte pression et à température élevée
dans les gisements à ce moment ses
produits son gazon d'un gisement non
tête de puits à température et pression
ambiante condense mais ça ça s'appelle
du condensat ça sous certaines
conditions une partie peut être
incorporé de l'essence mais si vous vous
intéressez à ce qui n'est que du vrai
pétrole
eh bien vous voyez un truc qui est
totalement passée sous silence dans la
presse mondiale qui est que la
production devrait pétrole n'augmente
plus depuis 2005
je répète
non selon sa dose non plus depuis 2005
qu'est ce que ça a comme conséquence le
fait que ça n'augmente plus depuis 2005
est bien la première conséquence est que
quand le gâteau est constant et que vous
avez plus d'invités à la table la part
de chaque invité des croix et si vous
avez en plus un des invités à la table
qui décide d'être de plus en plus
gourmands et par les autres d'accord
c'est très exactement ce qui est en
train d'arriver au pays de l' ocde
depuis 2006 depuis 2006
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de l' ocde
est en décrue subi et j'insiste c'est
subi c'est pas le génie de monsieur
borloo de madame royal et consorts et
des grünen et d'obama qui fait que ça
baisse c'est la géologie qui a décidé
d'être est mesquine avec nous de mettre
50 millions d'années pour faire du
pétrole et qui fait que depuis 2005 ça
sort plus de manière croissante
parce que nous sommes comme je le disais
au maximum et nous y sommes pas par
hasard
nous y sommes en héritage d'une tendance
que je vous ai montré ici qui dure
depuis un siècle et demi c'est pas une
surprise c'est pas une surprise
on n'est pas en train de découvrir à ma
chance de [ __ ] merde j'avais pas vu ça
où avec la tête
non c'est pas une surprise la bonne
question est de savoir pourquoi on a
refusé de le voir et qui donc vous voyez
que le pétrole baissent de manière
suivie depuis 2006 par ailleurs quand
vous voyez la consommation de chaque
énergie dans la zone ocde est vrai que
le pétrole arrive en premier le très bon
vous voyez aussi très bien le switch
charbon gaz notamment due aux etats unis
vainqueurs notamment due aux états unis
et vous voyez que si vous faites charbon
plus gadget endroit quelque chose d'à
peu près constante et comme le pétrole
était ici tout en bas vous avez les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables qui
sont là nucléaire hydroélectricité
vous voyez que si les nerfs le pétrole
est la première des nerfs
j ai baisse de manière contrainte à ce
moment là totalité de
l'approvisionnement énergétique se met à
baisser c'est encore plus marqué dans la
zone europe parce que le gaz
à la différence du pétrole est une
énergie régionales le pétrole est une
énergie mondiale c'est à dire que les
deux tiers du pétrole extrait dans le
monde passe une frontière entre la zone
de production et la zone de consommation
le gaz est une énergie régionales vous
n'avez que 30% du gaz extrait dans le
monde qui passe une frontière entre le
pays de production et le pays de
consommation donc la consommation de gaz
en europe est essentiellement le fait de
le mer du nord en mer du nord 2 fournit
60% du gaz européen la mer du nord est
en déclin géologiques depuis 2005
donc la quantité de gaz que l'europe
qu'on sauve et baisse depuis 2005 climat
doux pas climat doux et ça va continuer
donc en europe on a deux termes de
baisse et pas un seul le pétrole baisse
parce que l'approvisionnement ma zone
ocde baisse ça va continuer et le gaz
baisse parce que la mer du nord décline
et ça va continuer il touche et le bias
en europe n'est pas guéri ginger qu'on
en fasse ou qu'on en fasse pas
objectivement qu'on essaye d'en faire ou
pas ça ne changera strictement rien les
ordres de grandeur qui sont associés
techniquement le potentiel technique
vous parle pas du fait que les gens
soient d'accord ou pas le potentiel
technique de production chez le gaz en
europe et un à deux ordres de grandeur
en dessous de ce qu'il est aux états
unis donc même si on a envie de faire
des trous partout ça ne changera pas
tellement le destin de
l'approvisionnement gazier des européens
dans les 20 à 30 ans qui viennent
maintenant regardez la production
industrielle dans les pays de l' ocde
c'est quand même marrant valises à monte
vous voyez même pas aux rebelles les
champs pétroliers là dessus de 74 et 79
par contre le retournement
d'approvisionnement pétrolier en 2007 en
lui une voisine et si je vous montre les
pays de la zone europe ils sont encore
plus touchés parce que là dedans vous
avez les états unis qui grâce justement
à leurs suppléments d'approvisionnement
énergétique exactement au fait qu'ils
ont tamponné la baisse aux etats unis
sont aussi aujourd'hui en dessous de la
heureusement énergétique qu'ils avaient
en 2007 hmm hmm peu malgré la chaleur
shale gas mais ils y sont moins en
dessous que les européens pour les
européens la cour est encore plus
marquée pour les japonais va courber
plus marqué vous avez vu qu'il n'arrête
pas d'enchaîner les récessions depuis
et ça va continuer très bonne nouvelle
pour les japonais aussi alors pourquoi
est ce que je vous dis tout ça à cause
de neige
je vous dis tout ça à cause de la neige
parce que je vous ai parlé de la syrie
et je vous ai pas parlé de la tunisie et
de l'egypte dans les recettes à
l'exportation de la tunisie et de
l'egypte
vous ne trouvez pas les héros car de
lyon à la différence de la siagne par
contre vous trouvez les touristes
quand le pétrole tapez de plein fouet
les économies occidentales il que les
économies occidentales vont mal vous
faites ce que je disais tout à l'heure
donc le le dionysien l'égyptien lui
descend dans la rue parce que c'est ça
bouffe pour sa vie vous vous descendez
pas dans la rue mais vous arrêtez de
prendre l'avion pour aller en tunisie
donc la tunisie et l'egypte perdre des
recettes à l'exportation perdent des
touristes perdent le moyen de
subventionner l'alimentation par contre
sont confrontés au même marché mondial
que les autres sont confrontés aux mêmes
déficits en céréales avec une même
population qui a augmenté et sont un
foutu comme la syrie de subventionner
l'alimentation pour on va dire la
première moitié de la population qui a
besoin de déjà quasiment tout ce qu'elle
gagne pour bouffer est bon donc voilà
l'egypte premier importateur de blé au
monde vous le saviez peut-être pas les
hits importe car des céréales en qu'elle
consomme
c'est le premier importateur de blé au
monde les touristes sont pas là de
canicule en russie provoquent une
inflation sur les céréales la remontée
du pétrole provoque une inflation sur
les céréales le pétrole à des privés
nomi occidentale et donc les touristes
et vote de la fin la tunisie importe bon
an mal an la moitié de ces céréales
bis repetita pape touristes à cause du
pétrole plus des prix alimentaires qui
explose
plus les gens confondues priant émeutes
de la faim il ya les autres
voilà les autres ils n'ont pas eu un des
composants le maroc est globalement
autosuffisant sur le plan agricole
globalement donc si le prix des denrées
alimentaires augmentent
et bien c'est très ennuyeux pour ses
voisins lui ça nous regarde un peu moins
l'algérie par ailleurs non les dents ce
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure sur
l'évolution des précipitations
ici je vais plutôt vous le montrez là
parce que c'est
plus visible ce que vous voyez c'est que
vous avez des pays qui sont plus ou
moins touchés
et oui l'algérie est globalement la peu
moins touchées quand même que les autres
donc j'en reviens à ce que j'étais en
train de vous dire l'algérie est un peu
moins touchée que les autres et par
ailleurs l'algérie a toujours en
quantité
même si elle est au plateau du gaz et du
pétrole a exporté
or au même moment où les prix
alimentaires montrent le prix du pétrole
et du gaz remontent donc l'algérie peut
continuer à compenser pas de trouble
parce que sans vouloir vexer personne
dans la salle
si on essaye de comparer la légitimité
démocratique avant les émeutes de la
faim de la tunisie et de l'algérie je
pense qu'il y en ait matière à un long
débat donc je ne suis pas complètement
sûr que l'explication boboïsante
sympathique avancée par les médias
français qui était que ces gens-là
voulez la démocratie soit quelque chose
qui soit extrêmement discriminant dans
ce qui s'est passé vous savez comme moi
que si vous faites deux expériences avec
un paramètre où un certain nombre
d'expériences avec la valeur d'un
paramètre qui ne changent pas le
résultat de l'expérience et que ce
paramètre n'a pas d'importance
d'accord l'algérie n'a pas eu ces
problèmes alors les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets
l'assèchement du bassin méditerranéen va
continuer et il va continuer d'autant
plus vite que les chinois garderont des
centrales à charbon parce que c'est ça
le changement climatique il va continuer
d'autant plus vite que les autres pays
se fourvoie rond dans l'ordre de
priorité et pour traiter les changements
climatiques donc par exemple la france
continuera à penser que subventionner
des panneaux solaires chinois c'est plus
urgent que de s'occuper de mettre des
bus pour remplacer des bagnoles ceux ci
on avait mis le même argent qu'on met
dans les panneaux solaires apporté dans
les bus pour vous assurer qu'ils aient
un certain nombre de gens qu'ils
voteraient pas front national
aujourd'hui donc
très bonne manière de se tromper de
propres de santé solution c'est ce
trophée de problème vous connaissez
cette vieille maxime problème à moitié
pourrait bien poser déjà poker résolu
prenez-la contrat poser si vous posez
mal de problèmes vous n'avez aucune
chance de venir et donc les mêmes causes
ont produit les mêmes effets et c'est un
peu de ça que je vais vous parler
maintenant
vous avez ici la consommation mondiale
d'énergie depuis un siècle ethnique et
quand je disais les émissions viennent
bien de quelque part il vient bien de
quelque part
elles viennent de ce qu'on appelle les
combustibles fossiles qui ont l'immense
avantage d'avoir été fait par mère
nature pour pas un radis puisque je vous
rappelle dans cette salle personne n'a
payé le moindre centime pour que le
charbon le pétrole ou le gaz sous forme
donc quand vous entendez des écolos dix
ans le vent et le soleil sont gratuits
c'est vrai mais le pétrole le gaz et le
charbon sont gratuits aussi la seule
chose que ça coûte pour les pétrole le
gaz et le charbon c'est le travail
humain pour aller les chercher et les
sommes qu'il faut payer aux
propriétaires du moment s'il y en a un
pour qu'il accepte de s'en défaire tout
ça c'est des revenus humain ça ne
concerne pas la formation de la
ressource et d'une manière générale tout
ce qu'on va vous apprendre en économie
et en première approximation faut enfin
macroéconomie parce que par convention
et c'est des économistes place il ya
deux siècles que quelques dizaines
peut-être qu'à la fin le rat
quotidiennement ici je vous invite à
aller l'écouter notamment les ressources
naturelles sont gratuites
c'est jean baptiste say qui disait ça il
ya deux siècles donc en gros le code
génétique de 30 millions d'espèces
savons rien
donc du coup ça vaut rien et dézinguer
le climat ça vaut rien d'une ressource
naturelle le pétrole ça vaut rien donc
savons rien de le consommer et c'est en
ce qui concerne l'énergie
la seule chose qui compte c'est la
quantité de travail humain et les rentes
qu'il faut payer pour extraire un
kilowattheure de l'environnement mais le
kilowattheure dans l'environnement il a
existé sans que vous payer un centime et
par ailleurs la loi de conservation de
l'énergie que dans cette salle vous
connaissez tous
j'espère vous interdit de faire autre
chose en matière d'énergie que de
consommer un kilowattheure qui déjà
convié rendement corps n'est pas harry
potter vous pouvez pas créer l'énergie
ni merlin l'enchanteur c'est pas à votre
portée tout ce que vous pouvez faire
c'est d'aller chercher dans
l'environnement et kilowattheure qui
existe déjà elle veut consommer sans
vous pouvez faire et en fait vous ne
conservez pas vous transformez vous
augmentez son entreprise c'est tout ce
que vous pouvez faire alors la
thermodynamique vous interdit
formellement de faire quoi que ce soit
d'autre
et si vous faites la moindre
construction politique qui suppose de
viol et ça je parais toutes mes
économies par est transmissible à tous
les descendants que ça ne marchera pas
le paris jusqu'au dernier euro dont les
économies que ça ne marche pas si une
construction politique est décidée à
violer le premier principe de la thermo
vous donc le donc j'en reviens avec
combustibles fossiles pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en utilise plein des propos si
possible parce que ça vaut rien à
extraire parce que la nature a déjà
concentré l'énergie pour vous quand la
nature a concentré de pétrole dans le
désert saoudien vous les extrayez pour
0,3 centimes du kilowattheure
quand la nature tout ce qu'elle fait
c'est de déplacer de l'air à 80 km/heure
vous le faites pas c'est dans une
éolienne peut kilowattheure vous coûte 8
centimes
c'est à dire 30 fois plus c'est pas un
problème d'incurie des politiques cet
arbre et de physique donc l'idée qu'il
suffit d'investir dans les nerfs pour
remplacer les combustibles fossiles
il continue à vous garder erasmus est
des vols en avion et 40 mètres carrés
habitables par personne c'est faux juste
faux ça n'arrivera pas le simple fait de
promettre fait monter le front national
c'est tout ce que ça fait donc les
combustibles fossiles sont au coeur
aujourd'hui de l'approvisionnement
énergétique et ceci va avec ceux là
aussi sur les négociations climat par
lesquels je termine historiquement vous
constaterez qu on est bien passé des
renouvelables aux fossiles
on n'a pas fait la verse et si on n'est
pas passés des renouvelables aux
fossiles c'est que physiquement
tant qu'il ya pas de problème de limites
aux changements climatiques avec les
fossiles c'est quand même vachement plus
simple à utiliser que renouvelables
franchement plus est du reste ce que je
vous dis est tellement vrai que si vous
écoutez la presse française on n'arrête
pas d'investir dans les yeux
r si vous regardez les chiffres vous
avez une chanson un peu différente vous
avez ici l'augmentation de la
consommation mondiale d'énergie entre
2014 et 2015 je prends la consommation
en 2014
je me retranche la consommation de 2000
et je regarde ce qui a le plus augmenté
réponse le charbon il n'a pas un peu
plus augmenté que le solaire ou l'éolien
il a augmenté trente cinq fois plus que
le solaire est dix fois plus que
l'éolien donc pour le moment oublier
éolien et solaire
on s'en fout c'est pas notre problème ça
ne change rien ça ne change rien c'est à
dire que ça depuis qu'on a commencé à
investir jaune j'ai oublié de vous la
mettre là massivement le seul lien dans
le sel la maison je pourrais utiliser
cette expression dans le solaire et
l'éolien
l'intensité carbone de l'énergie dans le
monde c'est-à-dire la quantité de co2
qu'il faut mettre dans l'air pour
disposer d'un kilowattheures d'énergie a
arrêté de s'améliorer aujourd'hui en
télé 14
vous mettez autant de co2 dans l'air
quand vous utilisez un kilowattheures
d'énergie primaire que l'on devine donc
les sommes qui ont été investis dans
l'intervalle dans les nouvelles et je
vénère n'ont rien changé rien à
l'intensité carbone de l'énergie dans le
monde dont 1
si on veut être sérieux sur cette
affaire il faut pas s'occuper
d'augmenter de solaire faut s'occuper de
ses charmes
j'allais dire c'est pareil gare donc
c'est pas du tout pareil justement c'est
bien ça le sujet là encore on se trompe
d'objectif on se dit pas si on a là on à
l'autre pas nous vient de vous montrer
que nous on a augmenté solaire en tout
on apprend du tout fait baisser le
charbon
je vous disais une autre chose tout à
l'heure ça va continuer sur l'économie
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça va
continuer sur l'économie c'est que la
conclusion à laquelle je vais vous avez
tout de suite là maintenant c'est qu'il
va falloir transitionner sans croissance
non seulement il va falloir
transitionner sans croissance mais je
pense même qu'il va falloir conditionné
en récession vous avez ici à nouveau la
dérive et sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l' ocde
le fait qu'on soit passé par un maximum
en 2007 c'est pas du tout un hasard non
plus ce que vous voyez sur cette courbe
donc c'est votre se sent vraiment une
dérive et 1 mais vous voyez le taux de
croissance annuel de l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans la zone ocde
eh bien il ya 50 ans quand vos parents
enfants quand vos grands parents avaient
votre âge et bien pour les plus jeunes
c'est vraiment eu du mal à s en fait
pour moi si je meurs de linge a bien
profité
j'espère que les plus jeunes dans cette
salle aussi le temps de bien en profiter
donc le vous avez ici le taux de
croissance de 10 à 50 ans donc 4 % par
an puis ça descend à 3 puis elles sont à
double détente c'est à dire qu'il ya dix
ans puis ça descend à moins donc
maintenant la croissance et une
décroissance sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l'os et des sauces y
allant avec cela voilà comment a évolué
le taux de croissance du pib dans la
zone ocde
pourquoi est ce que les deux évoluent
ensemble parce que l'énergie c'est la
nourriture des machines et que le pipe
c'est à dire la production est faite par
des machines
la production est faite par des machines
c'est pas vous qui avez tissé vos
vêtements
c'est pas vous qui avait fait les bancs
sur lesquels vous êtes assis c'est pas
vous qui avez construit cet immeuble
c'est pas vous qui avait fait les moyens
de transport qui vous a amené ce matin
web il dit c'est par vous qui l'avez
fait pousser céréales
tout ça c'est des machines tout ça c'est
des machines les machines à faire
pousser des céréales sa faible des papes
au cracker des usines d'engrais des
usines de phytosanitaires détracteurs
des silos des trains à céréales plus
derrière des usines de transformation d
des cochons des abattoirs à cochon tout
ça c'est ce qui a produit votre bouche
c'est des machines ce qui a produit
aurait pu lancer les machines cela
produit au logement schl les machines ce
qui a produit l'avion dans lequel vous
partirez peut-être en vacances c'est de
la chine
et c'est toute la production aujourd'hui
est faite par des machines et les
machines mange de l'énergie moins
d'énergie moins de machines mois une
machine de production ça marche
extrêmement bien
c'est la raison pour laquelle production
industrielle dans tous les pays de la
cedeao décline depuis 2007 si c'était
juste une affaire d'arnaud montebourg
local totalement incapable on devrait
voir le résultat en france et pas chez
les autres on le voit partout sauf à ce
que les clones est ce que je ne crois
pas et bien c'est que vous avez une
cause structurelle qui est supra par
rapport au fait d'avoir des politiques
ont conclu que les mac os structurelles
supra vous l'avez l'a donc le taux de
croissance de la zone ocde il existe
toujours mais il décroît et si vous
prenez l'europe
on est à l'intersection de la droite de
régression avec l'axé a6 dit autrement
je pense qu'à partir de maintenant
l'avenir européen s'est créé dans un
monde sans croissance et même en
récession structurelles donc là où de
plus en plus c'était la règle c'est de
moins en moins qui va devenir la règle
alors ça pose quelques petits problèmes
notamment celui du choix des gens à qui
on confie les affaires de la cité parce
que en période de croissance il n'y a
pas de mauvais manager d'accord
distribuer durable de sucettes dans un
monde il ya plus en plus de sucettes une
tâche facile pour des premiers convenu
en général y gagne par contre gérer la
décroissance de la quantité de sucettes
au sein d'une population qui en voudrait
toujours autant ça ça demande une
habileté et un talent qui ne sont pas
donné à tout le monde qu'ils ne sont pas
donné à tout le monde donc il va falloir
qu'on choisit soigneusement
malheureusement l'offre pas terrible en
ce moment mais il va falloir vous choisi
soigneront la deuxième conséquence que
ça importe c'est que dès lors qu'on se
dit qu'on va transitionner avec des
moyens supplémentaires par rapport à ce
qu'on consacre à ce qu'on fait déjà
on est en train d'élaborer un plan qui
fera faillite
donc nous sommes à l'heure des choix est
de plus en plus à l'heure des choix on
n'aura pas un fromage et dessert donc
dans les bâtiments j'aurais par la norme
handicapés plus la norme ce aussi plus
la dame cela plus l'isolation
le nom devoir choisir j'aurais pas plus
de pognon pour l'hôpital puisse plus
pour les juges plus plus pour les flics
plus plus pour l'éducation nationale
plus plus pour partir en vacances plus
plus pour les soldes la falloir choisir
on est vraiment aujourd'hui à l'heure
des choix et ses choix évidemment
d'autres vont les vivre comme nous et
j'en reviens au pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen
petit aparté vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
on vient de voter en france la loi de
transition énergétique espèces
d'assemblage curieux qui mêle quelques
objectifs intelligent avec d'autres
beaucoup plus stupide et l'essentiel des
mesures concrètes contenues dans la loi
sur le problème que nous n'avons pas
vous avez sûrement entendu tous le fait
que la france est un pays tout nucléaire
qui n'a jamais entendu cette expression
dans la salle vous avez ici l'énergie
mangés par les machines en france
j'insiste sur le fait qu'elle n'est pas
le consommer par les individus car si
vous consommiez directement l'énergie
vous boire y est directement du pétrole
vous mettrez directement vos doigts dans
la prise que je vous déconseille vous
mangeriez directement du charbon ce
qu'une sex shops aux flatulences
particulière vous ne concerne pas
l'énergie vous ordonner des machines
enfin vous donnez des ordres les
machines qui vont sauver nergie d'accord
c'est votre frigo notre ce pirate heures
qui concerne l'énergie ou encore une
fois vous mettez pas les voit la reprise
donc vous avez ici l'énergie consommée
par les machines en fonction de l'abs
sont les machines quand les machines des
places des gens et des marchandises ça
s'appelle des camions des avions des
voitures à ses dents transports quand
les machines font pousser des vestes et
des shows aux élèves des vestiaires et
c'est donc les trieuses et des
moissonneuses batteuses avec kant et la
chine produit des objets voire quelques
services l'objet c'est dans l'industrie
quand tu es machine assure le confort
des gens qui sont dans un bureau ou dans
la salle dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui
ça s'appelle tertiaire là vous
travaillez et quand vous étudiez et
quand les machines assure le confort de
l'art vous habitez ça s'appelle
résidence me l'ordonné de ce graphique
c'est des milliards de kilowattheures
vous savez que toute énergie peuvent
être con
ayant kilowattheure puisque si les
physiciens dans le jour là vont
multiplier le juge par trois multi
studio on dirait qu'ils auraient tous
comptés en kilowatt heure le pétrole le
gaz le charbon pas seulement
l'électricité et maintenant je vais
cercle et toutes les énergies toutes les
consommations énergétiques en france dit
final donc celle qui rentrent dans une
machine qui proviennent des combustibles
fossiles
je vous repose la question est ce que la
france est un pays tout nucléaire
est-ce que vous pensez que les
journalistes correctement leur métier
quand depuis des années les années des
années des années ils vous disent que la
france est un pays de nucléaire
la réponse est non j'en tire une autre
conclusion que je vous livre tout de
suite
ne croyez jamais ce qui est écrit dans
le journal sauf si vous connaissez
personnellement le journaliste et que
vous l'avez vu à l'offre sur des sujets
que vous connaissez déjà à ces deux
conditions près vous pouvez croire ce
qu'il ya dans journal sinon par principe
ce qui est dans le journal n'est jamais
opposable il ya sept ans gardant bah oui
c'est emmerdant
oui c'est emmerdant mais c'est comme ça
mon père qui était physicien m'a
toujours ébahi par une caractéristique
qu'il avait à être avalisée d un truc tu
connais peut-être sa toile les systèmes
columbia records jamais su à quoi ça
servait j'ai encore moins su comment s'y
attaquer mais bon apparemment il était
pas volé son score c'était deux
dimensions à deux dimensions pardon
alors faire encore pire
et d'après j'ai découvert je ne savais
pas bon je sais que mon nom est associé
un truc qui doit faire chier quatre
études leurs parents j'ai six points
donc le
donc le ceux qui y allant journal je le
disais n'est malheureusement pas
opposable parce que c'est fait de
raccourcis pour gagner de la place
les raccourcis pour gagner de la place
charrie toujours des malentendus
toujours toujours toujours la france en
matière d'énergie ne s'intéresse qu'à
l'électricité parce que c'est le seul
truc que vous pouvez montrer avec une
caméra qui se promènent en france vous
ne pouvez pas montrer un peu de pétrole
y en a pas photo entre un pégase y en a
pas pour ne pas montrer une mine de
charbon et n'a pas donc vous avez une
caméra vous balader entre ne sont pas
les dons qu'on s'intéresse qu'à
l'électricité
j'allais le dire c'est quand même
extraordinaire que ça fait si ça marche
comme ça je connais 800 journalistes
croit jacques seck puisqu'il participe à
une des aventures dans ce domaine on a
monté une école divers pour journalistes
dès maintenant 10 ans fin n'était pas
leur époque mais moi si j'en ai vu
passer des centaines
je pousse assure que c'est une
profession dans laquelle les gens
peuvent être individuellement très bien
c'est pas le sujet il ya une limitation
structurelle à l'exercice du métier de
journaliste qui vous produit pas
construction du bien entendu par
construction corp même si les gens à
titre individuel sont des gens très bien
ayant donc vous avez eue s'il baisse la
quantité sur son blog qui n'est pas du
journalisme par ailleurs il a 30 ans
d'expérience donc effectivement vous
avez quelques journalistes en france qui
sont des journalistes remarquable parce
que d'abord il dévie pas leur sujet
ensuite ils bossent et
voilà qu'ils finissent par ne plus tirer
de conclusions hâtives sont là la loi de
transition énergétique s'intéresse
essentiellement l'électricité c'est à
dire par d'autres problèmes
un autre problème quand on parle de
changement climatique qui provoque les
insurrections dans le pourtour
méditerranéen et au sahel et dans
l'afrique australe parce que c'est que
le début dans un dernier en avoir
d'autres de plus en plus avant que le
lire ou voir j'étais avec une personne
qui dit moi je pense que le sahel c'est
la prochaine tous derrière c'est aussi
une zone qui s'assèchent c'est aussi une
aujourd'hui à plein de monde c'est aussi
une zone instable
c'est aussi soit dit en passant les
puissances coloniales zone les
puissances coloniales ont fait des pays
avec des frontières toutes droites sans
tenir compte de la répartition des
religions des ethnies des cultures c'est
quand même ça vous a peut être étonné
vous regardez une carte de france
la frontière elle arrête pas de faire
des hybrides oui parce que ça suit les
lignes de crêtes et rivières les machins
et c c'est-à-dire des frontières
naturelles qui ont historiquement
délimiter des populations séparés par
des cultures et des religions
différentes
historiquement les noms il vivait en
important regardez les pays du
moyen-orient vous avez que des
frontières tout droite
pourquoi vous avez des frontières tout
droite parce que les puissances
coloniales ont créé les pays du
moyen-orient ces temps le pétrole
essentiellement l'arabie saoudite est
une création des américains l'irak est
une création des anglais la syrie est
une création des français enfin voilà on
s'est partagé le pétrole et on s'est
partagé le pétrole en mettant la moitié
des kurdes d'un côté votre moitié de
l'autre et aujourd'hui vous avez donc
des zones qui sont j'allais dire non
homogène dès que vous avez un élément de
déstabilisation externe qui vient s'y
appliquer comme ça vous fait ça me fiche
du bordel exactement comme en france des
vous avez un peu de le début de
contraction économique les bretons
disent laissez nous être breton et les
génial laissez-nous être auvergnats
c'est très humain quand c'est toujours
comme ça donc le pétrole est l'un des
problèmes
il fait deux tiers de notre co2 et il
fait quelques dizaines de milliards
dollars de déficit commercial par an le
gaz est notre deuxième problème le
charbon est encore un petit problème
l'uranium à porter fait entre 0,5 et 1
milliard de dollars par an donc
rapporter à ce que ça produit c'est un
problème secondaire apporter ce que ça
produit cet après midi je vais revenir
au changement climatique
donc pour le moment nous n'en voyons que
les débuts 'business as usual' vous avez
ici qui sera pas que je lui vous avez
ici une carte d'europe qui vous
représentent les écosystèmes installer
si on leur fout la paix quand ça veut
dire quoi qu on leur fout la paix qu'on
ne défrise pas pour faire des champs on
ne va pas les forêts pour faire ou qu'on
ne supprime pas quelques bouts de bois
pour faire paris saclay et qu' on ne
crée pas des routes les machins et les
choses
oui c'est essentiellement des forêts
dire que c'est essentiellement des
forêts dire que y faire raisonnablement
doubs s'est pas trop chaud qui fait
vraiment trop chaud même s'il pleut
facile peut énormément ça va mais en
juin quand il fait très chaud il ya des
endroits où il fait un peu trop sec
et par ailleurs il peut suffisamment
donc vous faites pousser ce qui a la
plus grosse partie émergée dans les
divers types de végétaux tout au nord il
fait froid et sec dont vous n'êtes pas
de forme tout à l'est
il fait chaud et sec dont vous n'avez
pas de forêt la forêt voici l'europe
pyramide à l'europe il ya vingt mille
ans alors le trader c'est moi qui l'ait
mis à la main parce que l'anti n'envoyez
pas bien c'est leur écoute
d'accord c'est ce qui sépare les terres
émergées alors très bonne très mauvaise
nouvelle pour les banques un pardon on
est au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire d'accord qui froid il y avait
20 août
alors il ya une première nouvelle c'est
que vous ne pouvez pas aller en erasmus
hockey th en suède parce que les suédois
sont sous la glace donc mauvaise
nouvelle pour les français qui a mis
suédoise
mauvaise nouvelle pour les françaises
qui a mis norvégien tous ces beaux
manteaux de bronze à la personne
puisqu'il ya trois kilomètres de plage
posez dessus
mauvaise nouvelle pour les français et
françaises qui aiment les québécois n'y
a pas plus de québécois soit dit en
passant
le canada est également sous la glace
d'une énorme calotte de trois kilomètres
d'épaisseur s'appelle laurentides qui
ont posé sur le canada vous voyez qu'on
peut [ __ ] la pâtée aux écossais au
taureau destination parce que ils seront
sous la place aussi donc c'est facile et
les bonnes années on peut battre les
irlandais dont les très bonnes années
sans prendre
eurotunnel ou le ferry puisque il n'y a
plus la mer du nord et la manche tousart
disparu parce que sega lot qui se sont
constitués ont dû prendre l'eau quelques
pas pour exister l'ol ont pris dans
l'océan l'océan est une grosse baignoire
si vous prenez de l'eau dedans
le niveau de la baignoire baisse donc le
niveau de l'océan a baissé de plus de
100 mètres encore mais pour moi qui
adore faire de la voile en manges tu
embrasses clamant je n'existe plus
boyer que comme il fait plus froid il
fait plus sec et comme il fait plus sec
la végétation installé n'a rien à voir
en gros vous avez en europe la
végétation qui est aujourd'hui installée
sur le nord de la sibérie
petit changement en ce qui concerne les
écosystèmes dans ce genre de paysage
l'europe est capable de subvenir aux
besoins alimentaires de la population de
boulogne billancourt ou d'un petit
arrondissement parisien
c'est tout ce que la terre te la france
pendant le capable de nourrir à cette
époque quand la terre est passé du
paysage de gauche au paysage de droite
tous que la température moyenne a fait
c'est de monter de 5 de grippe par 50 ou
pas 505 regarder ce qui est déjà en
train de se passer sur le stress pour un
certain nombre de populations avec zéro
point du 7° 2
et imaginez en fait vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer moins non plus c'est
inimaginable au sens premier du terme
ça n'a pas de sens d'imaginer dans le
détail c'est hors de votre capacité
intellectuelle et or de la vienne on ne
peut pas on peut approcher vous dirai
après truc qualitatif mais penser qu' on
sait prédire dans un monde qui se
réchauffe de 4,7 degrés que le 3 janvier
2000 86 vous allez avoir 51,2 millions
de personnes qui vont mourir de la
grippe au vietnam
ça n'a aucun sens aucun aucun aucun
aucun corps ne pouvait pas dire ce genre
de choses
tout ce que vous pouvez dire c'est que
quand vous voyez ce qui s'est produit
dans le passé avec juste 5 degrés de
hausse en cinq milan 0 1 degré par
siècle sur 50e vraisemblablement que le
résultat des courses si on s'amuse à
cette expérience-là sera beaucoup plus
désagréable que l'idée qu'on s'en fait
aujourd'hui est par ailleurs l'autre
chose qu'on peut dire c'est que les
conséquences vont s'appliquer avec des
coups de billard à trois bandes ce que
j'ai essayé de vous expliquer sur le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen il m'a
fallu 20 minutes pour ça vous avez
jamais 20 minutes sur une radio vous
avez jamais permis d'acter c'est que
jamais d'un millier dans un journal
visait à voix haute le contenu d'une
interview dans le journal
vous avez vu en trois minutes 30 vous
avez vous arriver au bout donc
l'explication longue sur le coup de
billard à trois bandes vous ne l'aurez
jamais dans les grands médias encore les
grands médias c'est ce que les élus en
démocratie consulte avant tout le reste
de ce fait les premières conséquences
les plus désagréables du couple
énergique l'inrap confère la crise
financière que personne ne relie aux
chocs pétroliers dans les discours
meanstream confère la crise du bassin
méditerranéen que très peu de gens
reliés aux changements climatiques dans
le discours meanstream les premières
conséquences très désagréable les gens
ne verront pas dans la sphère
décisionnelle le lien avec le problème à
traiter
ils continueront à penser que le
déterminant premier est d'ailleurs que
là où il est donc on continuera à ne pas
s'occuper du déterminant premier et il
va falloir attendre qu'on soit très
avancée si on laisse l'expérience menée
jusqu'à son terme
dans ce que de vouloir y appelait la
chienlit pour finir par comprendre qu'il
aurait fallu faire quelque chose à un
moment où il sera trop tard pour ça
parce que l'inertie du système
climatique est absolument considérable
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'entre le
moment où on va commencer à baisser les
émissions et le moment où les dernières
conséquences sur le changement
climatique vont se stabiliser il va
falloir attendre des milliers d'années
où des dizaines de milliers d'années
donc ya pas de bouton reset encore il
n'ya pas de bouton et 7
donc au moment où vous dites merde
j'aurais pas dû vous n'avez pas plus la
possibilité de revenir en arrière qu'au
moment où vous jeter de la tour eiffel
arrivé au premier étage les nerfs
j'aurais pas dû trop tard c'est
exactement pareil pour le changement
climatique alors je veux pas désagréable
en vous disant ça c'est juste que c'est
ça le cahier des charges du problème il
ne faut pas se retrouver dans la
situation où je dis merde j'aurais pas
dû ce qui est inédit pour les spéciaux
mais l'espèce humaine en général apprend
par essai erreur
donc on fait l'essai mais là on peut pas
s'ils ont fait l'essai dans les
conséquences je vous le dis encore une
fois c'est qualitatif et la
quantification dépendra de place tout un
tas de trucs dont le nombre de centrales
à charbon qu'on aura en chine il y aura
des conséquences sur la sécurité
alimentaire donc sur les des politiques
à londres est comme diraient les anglo
saxons il ya ça il y aura des
conséquences évidemment sur les
écosystèmes installés et les écosystèmes
installez vous savez que sans eux on est
tous morts puisque si vous supprimez la
totalité des écosystèmes installé par le
supprimer
les ressources qui nous servent à manger
et scénario qui viennent beaucoup de
morts l'idée qu'on peut taper dans
l'environnement avec une économie qui se
porte bien c'est une chimère c'est une
vue de l'esprit ça n'existe pas
l'économie est un sous-ensemble de
l'environnement epa leur dire vous allez
avoir des conséquences sur les zones en
début de maladie parce que la
biodiversité des agents pathogènes va
profiter de la faire comme d'autres
vous allez avoir des variations des vals
de chaque fois une augmentation des
vagues de chaleur sont pas prêtes
impliqués a imaginé le niveau de ces on
va monter parce que l'eau chaude
ce deal à 20 l'eau se réchauffe ans vit
date et mon dos et on est dans une
grande baignoire le niveau de l'eau
monte et vous avez un certain nombre de
glace ont opposé sur le père ferme dont
maintenant le gros aimant qui a commencé
à fondre à qui vont alimenter cette
hausse aussi le co2 émis dans l'air
passe pour partie dans l'océan où il a
sidi philo ça va poser des problèmes à
une partie de la vie marine la
circulation asiatiques à grande échelle
écrit modifié sans que l'on sache
exactement ce que ça peut donner à
l'échéance de quelques siècles
si on va jusqu'au bout de l'expérience
les phénomènes intenses vont
s'intensifier parce que les phénomènes
intense viennent d'une conviction elle
même importante
et quand vous réchauffer la surface pour
reprendre ses astra taux seraient en
fait des formes et le profil vertical de
température de l'atmosphère
donc vous augmentez de l'étape
températures entre surface stratosphère
donc vous augmenter la puissance
convectifs de tous les vêtements de tous
les phénomènes collectifs donc
raisonnablement il faut s'attendre à une
augmentation de la puissance unitaire
des tornades et des cyclones peut-être
même des orages pas complètement stupide
de penser que ce serait bien le
groenland a commencé à fondre et il va
continuer à le faire jusqu'à la
prochaine entrée en de l'association si
lente et qu'elle arrive pour le moment
c'est toujours prévu qu'il arrive
passé un certain niveau de changement
climatique on rentre dans l'inconnu elle
arrive en tête ratait pas enfin au bout
de quelques centaines de milliers
d'années c'est sûr que oui
la prochaine prochaine ça devient un
point d'interrogation et l'antarctique
de l'ouest ici a aussi commencé à se
désintégrer loos le groenland au total
ces six mètres dos à ses 3,4 et le
groenland va fondre à une vitesse est
inconnue ça va encore une fois dépend du
nombre de centrales à charbon en chine
et ailleurs
vous avez des stocks de carbone qui
était immobile depuis des centaines des
dizaines de milliers ou des millions
d'années qui vont se remettre en
circulation et tout ça comme je le
disais va avoir des conséquences
directes et indirectes c'est bien
évidemment les conséquences indirectes
qui ont été plus de ram
aujourd'hui la restriction alimentaire
dans les pays du maghreb fait plus de
morts en un directs et indirects
les gens ne meurent pas de faim stricto
sensu par contre le fait qu'ils ont
commencé à prendre les armes a déjà fait
son vivant ciel donc c'est des
conséquences indirectes qui seront les
plus graves les conséquences indirectes
sont évidemment les plus difficile à
modéliser comme nous faisons une
expérience pour la première fois je le
dis je le répète je me répète
n'imaginais pas une seconde que ça a du
sens de demander aux scientifiques de
vous faire le menu des cours ça avance
ça n'a pas de sens
ça n'a pas de sens alors évidemment
mobiliser les gens sur des conséquences
qu'on n'est pas capable de quantifier et
très précisément à l'avance c'est
compliqué c'est plus simple pour moi de
vous suggérer de vous assurer contre un
accident de voiture si vous avez une
fourchette de ce que ça peut vous coûter
si vous avez un accident de voiture
si je vous dis ça vous coûte n'importe
quoi entre 0 et le plus saint philippe
plus compliqué et là on est
malheureusement dans une fourchette
d'incertitude sur les conséquences qui
est extrêmement large
ça peut aller de n'importe quoi
reprendre on aura cinq ans d'espérance
de vie en moins jusqu'à la moitié de la
population y passe et l'autre moitié
voit son espérance de vie -ramenée
récemment j'ai aucune angoisse pour
l'espèce humaine tout de suite l'espèce
humaine s'en sortira très bien mais
c'est une espèce qui va s'en sortir
nombre de représentants de l'espèce ça
c'est moins suivre l'espèce en tant
qu'espèce a très bien survécu aux pestes
du moyen-âge extrêmement bien encore
sauf qu'à cette époque la moitié de la
population du passé
donc l'espèce en tant qu'espèce ce n'est
aucune angoisse bien focus sur un très
bon nombre de représentants de l'espèce
c'est un des membres est maintenant si
on veut pas alors je sais que jacques il
y croit pas moi je vais faire semblant
d'y croire quand même jusqu'à la fin de
l'exposé en fait qu'andy camjac dit j'y
crois pas c'est une manière de dire je
ne crois pas aux contreparties
parce que physiquement c'est possible
sauf que lui dit les contreparties
sociologiques économiques avec le schéma
mental qui est celui des hommes je pense
qu'elles n'arriveront pas cet appareil
composé moi je vais juste essayer vous
expliciter un peu plus quantitativement
ou sur les ondes et par ailleurs je vais
vous le savez dû sortir le paradigme du
fumeur qui est que quand vous fumez vous
allez devoir intérêt à baisser votre
consommation cigarette même si vous
arrêtez pas complètement vous avez aussi
une droite
alors je vous ai pas sorti l'autre
droite qui est majeur dans cette affaire
qui est énergie pib mais c'est pas grave
donc il ya deux droites qu'il faut
absolument connaître quand on s'occupe
du problème celle-ci c'est la deuxième
set droite elle vous dit en fonction de
ce que seront les émissions cumulées de
l'humanité entre 1870 1850 paris et 2100
donc je prends la totalité de ce que
l'humanité et met entre 252 listes et je
le mets sur l'accent compte je dire
après à partir de cet axe je leur porte
sur l' axe vertical et ça me donne
d'élévation de température planétaire
que j'aurai en 2100 par rapport à 1850
quand même sa part le film qu'on entend
relayer toute simple application
numérique en 2015 nous avons émis à peu
près 2000 milliards de tonnes de co2
entre 1853 dix chansons disent tous
pareils et 2015 et donc et donc nous
avons signé pour 1,1 quelque chose
degrés en 2100 par rapport à 1850 comme
évidemment il ya une zone d'incertitude
c'est 1,2 plus ou moins 0,3
vous voyez on pouvait renverser le
raisonnement on dit on veut 2 degrés
alors plus ou moins quelque chose eh
bien ça veut dire que nous avons droit à
trois mille milliards de tonnes de co2
émises dans l'atmosphère d'ici à 2100
c'est la notion de budget carbone j'ai
encore droit d'émettre mille milliards
de tonnes équivalent co2 3 2 sur 2
qu'est ce que c'est l'univers de tonnes
c'est juste la combustion des réserves
prouvées de pétrole
donc à partir de demain matin je vous
dis tout au charbon donc tout ce qui
éveille line charbon stellaire made in
china
vous avez plus grande lâcheté ou encore
le droit de prendre vos bagnoles 2 vous
chauffer au fioul
voilà on reste aux oubliés ça c'est les
gars de tonnes de budget rien que sur le
pétrole je peux dire je vais être un peu
plus sévère sur le pétrole
donc j'en utilise pas 1000 milliards
j'utilise 700 ou 800 à ce moment je me
relâche un peu la pression sur le gaz
mais encore le droit de chauffer un peu
au gaz pendant
22 30 ans les parle de 120 le temps ou
alors ça vous donne une petite idée de
ce que signifie respecter les deux
degrés donc on n'est pas en train de
parler d'un machin qui est un acte grave
et on va signer ça va se mettre d'accord
apparition 2° youplaboum je peux
retourner tranquille incombe dick roche
pendant que j'ai réécouté découvre
maintenant tout ça c'est demain matin on
oblige vos parents ou vous même si vous
êtes propriétaire parler de votre
logement
on vous dit à bagnols hassidique la
d'oubli tu vas en prendre une à deux et
puis si tu fais pas ça jo qui perd pacs
l'avion je multiplie prix du billet
d'avion par cinq
voilà c'est ça le monde à deux balles
c'est simplement ça devrait vous en
voulez pas vous aurez la guerre mais
c'est comme ça que se posent des
questions
donc c'est pour ça que j'y crois pas
mais il pense qu'on préfèrera la guerre
parce qu'on prend qu'elle va pas arriver
moi je vous dis que moi je pense qu'elle
va arriver donc je préfère ce que je
suis en train de vous raconter mais
c'est bien ça les termes de l'équation
vue de masse contre il vous comprendrez
pourquoi quand je vous dis ça j'en veux
tant aux écologistes bon teint qui pense
qu'il est urgent de dépenser des
milliards dans les panneaux solaires
parce que c'est la meilleure preuve
qu'ils soient qu'on ne croie pas mon
problème
si vous croyez vraiment qu'on est en
train de risquer la guerre vous
commencez pas par fout de vos milliards
dans un truc qui sert à 1 on commençait
parfaitement milliards en un truc qui
sert à éviter ce qui va causer la galère
est d'accord et entre vous et moi entre
l' insurrection généralisée dans tous
les pays limitrophes de l'europe et les
conséquences chez nous le fait qu'une
fois tous les vingt ans on est vécue
sans vie de personnes parce qu'on n'est
pas foutu de gérer nos centrales
nucléaires je préfère très nettement la
deuxième option qui compte répond moi je
vais partir traitement être évacués une
fois tous les vingt ans plus tôt que les
enfants te recrache qu'ont ceux qui sont
là vivent 20 pays en moins probable
la gazière aux photos là dessus donc si
on veut pas à quoi encore s'attaquer
et bien voici la décomposition alors
évidemment je voulais pas à l'avancé
tous août le camp lorsque vous commencez
à voir ça la décomposition des émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre
aujourd'hui 20% des émissions mondiales
viennent des seules centrales à charbon
retenez deux chiffres vous avez 63
gigawatts de centrales nucléaires en
france sur lesquelles on n'arrête pas de
s'écharper comme si c'était notre
premier problème il y à 1800 gigawatts
de centrales au charbon dans le monde 30
fois la puissance du parc nucléaire
français en centrale à charbon dans le
si nous voulons être sérieux au sur les
2 degrés il faut tout l'est m à la
ferraille dans les 30 ans qui viennent
tout
départ en train de parler de ses pas il
des panneaux solaires qu'on va y arriver
pensez vous trente ans pour ses parts au
2050 quand on se laissera vente et non
dans les 30 ans qui viennent on commence
demain vous avez 6 % qui viennent les
centrales à gaz et les centrales à
pétrole car il reste les centrales à
pétrole vous avez 5 % deux des émissions
mondiales qui sont dues à la seule
production de ciment donc faire des
villes 5% pour le ciment et encore 3 4%
pour l'acier puisque large partie de
l'acier est utilisé dans des choses qui
s'utilise en ville démotivant pour
commencer et ensuite un certain nombre
d'infrastructures et la tour eiffel donc
5 % des émissions mondiales de gaz à
effet de serre production ici pour vous
qu'il ya des chimistes distinguer deux
tiers viennent du fait qu'on prix du
cacao ont cessé à ses os 3 qui devient
ca opus co2 donc ça tant qu'on rit du
caire dont on n'y échappe pas donc à
moins de faire des lions hydraulique
avec autre chose que du cac a brillé ce
qu'on peut faire
eh bien on continue à passer par les
émissions et un tiers du total vient du
combustible dont il dit seuls quelques
heures à température ambiante qui
véritable le reste de l'industrie c'est
10% et là dedans l'essentiel c'est la
production de matériaux de base
donc c'est la production de plastique
dans chimie de base donc vous êtes des
cinq cochons
la production d'acier de non ferreux et
c'est ça qui va faire l'essentiel des
émissions ensuite transformé l'acier en
trombone ou en gros de trottinettes ça
c'est très peu émissifs et les chimistes
que vous êtes le sert très bien et
physiciens aussi dur exactement les deux
c'est quand vous avez des gros besoins
de chaleur pour transformer la matière
vous avez vos émissions quand vous
n'avez besoin que de force mécanique des
émissions sont tout de suite beaucoup
plus basses dont l'usiné est travaillée
assemblée etc
c'est pas très intensif en émission
on transforme et réduire en particulier
ça c'est hyper intensifs en l'émission
réduire ces extraire l'oxygène est la
meilleure manière qu'on a d'extraire le
cij nc de la sociedade carbone tous les
hauts fourneaux d'où le co2 de la
métallurgie
voilà vous avez 6%
donc ça on ne diminuera pas alors
qu'est-ce que ça on peut faire des liens
autrement et puis - construire et ça on
peut moins concernés donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut refaire des objets qui vont
coûter plus cher qui dureront plus
longtemps qu'ils n'auront pas des
performances techniques qui vont
s'améliorer tous les quatre matins qui
seront réparées quand ils marcheront pas
et qui vont vous coûter plus cher
donc quand votre vis de votre branches
de lunettes [ __ ] le camp
vous présidez très page et l'opticien en
disant tiens c'est l'occasion de changer
de modèle
vous commencez par mettre un bout de
sparadrap et ensuite vous irez chez un
opticien qui pour 100 euros vous aurez
par aventure en étant juste une disent
d'accord en vue l'exemple de loterie
sien est peut-être mal choisie parce que
c'est les commerçants les mieux payés
france aurait-elle dû rentrer en
d'autres qui ont un peu plus le besoin
de frotter
mais peu importe c'est pour vous donner
un exemple un peu concrets de je vais
pas jeter acheter et du coup évidemment
ici lors enfin de moins bonnes affaires
puisque vous referai pas rouvert à
chaque fois que vous avez une vie ce qui
fout le camp sur vos montures de
lunettes
donc ça va totalement déplacé l'économie
et vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi
avec ce genre de trucs
les gagnants ont gagné mais enfin ils
sont pas encore assez visible mais ya
beaucoup de perdants comprennent tous
envie de perdre quand il doit peut-être
que c'est il ya des trucs plus urgents
peut-être qu'on ferait mieux de
s'occuper de la pauvreté la pollution ne
sais pas quoi un peu comme si quelqu'un
vous disait vous avez vous risquez la
gangrène au bras droit
vous n'avez pas de solution évidente à
vous dire ouais enfin peut-être que je
prévienne m'occuper de l'ongle incarné
du pied gauche quand même si vous voulez
vous allez devoir vous occuper des deux
à la fois le les chaudières de bâtiments
font 6% dans le monde alors en france et
25 dans le monde ces six parce qu'une
bonne partie de l'humanité vit dans des
endroits on n'a pas besoin de chauffer
par contre y'a besoin climatisé ce qui
induit une
artix de ça dans les 14 % qui sont dues
aux transports se voyait apparaître une
voiture les voitures mondiales c4 les
camions mondiaux c4 les navires mondiaux
c3 et les avions mondiaux auraient fait
dans la stratosphère ces deux retenez un
truc qui va peut-être vous étonner les
cochons de chimistes qui font du
plastique et du ciment et mettre plus
que les voitures dans le monde
donc vous qui êtes dans une école où
vous allez devoir un peu vous occuper de
ce genre de secteur occupez-vous
beaucoup de ce genre de problème
beaucoup beaucoup pour 20% des émissions
mondiales et du fait qu'on mange
et là c'est très simple pour baisser ses
émissions il faut manger ou un gros
animaux c'est pour ça que le schiste
s'apprête à se faire beaucoup d'amis en
proposant qu' en france on divise
cheptel bovin pardon alors comme les
éleveurs font un métier considérablement
plus dur que le vôtre il se lève plus
tôt
il se couche plus tard ils ont moins de
vacances et il ya une moins bien leur
vie qu'un ingénieur sorti de cette école
on va évidemment réfléchir à la manière
que tout le monde perdent sauf mais il
ya quand même un sujet en gros il faut
monter le truc en valeur en regard deux
fois moins et faire en sorte que
c'est pas ordonner les éleveurs quant
aux gens cette histoire très bonne
manière de faire étant un truc
totalement anti libérale qui s'appelle
remettre en place des quotas et on a un
vrai sujet pour résoudre ce problème qui
s'appelle la pensée libérale et la
pensée du marché et dont je suis très
content de retrouver dans quelques
heures un ancien président film dix ans
le marché faut pas oublier la
déforestation qui est un déterminant
amont de l'agriculture c'est pour sambre
quand je dis amen parce que l'essentiel
du défrichage dans le monde il ya deux
déterminants principaux ou défrichage
c'est du bois de feu et l'augmentation
des surfaces au sol sur une terre qui
continue à accueillir de nouveaux
habitants pour baisser les émissions
dues à ça il ya deux choses qui font
d'elle il faut toucher il ya le régime
alimentaire et la démocratie donc il
faut aussi remettre sur la table un
débat difficile douloureux qui est le
débat sur la démographie est là aussi
pour dire des choses désagréables je
pense qu'en france les aides fiscales
pro nataliste sont des passes il faut
faire l'inversé
parce que comme c'est les machines qui
produisent et par les hommes
l'idée sympathique que en augmentant la
population augmente le pib et tout va
bien
fausse c'est en augmentant l'énergie qui
alimentait machine que vous augmentez le
pays des si vous avez l'énergie qui
baisse c'est la population qui augmente
vous augmentez pour c'est tout ce que
vous faites
moi je dis peut-être il faut réfléchir
avant de faire des pauvres peut-être
qu'ils vont mieux qui est un peu moins
de monde et qui soit un peu plus haut
ça se discute évidemment ça va toucher à
ma retraite
donc au lieu d'avoir à mont joli
pavillon de banlieue où on sera deux à
la retraite et bunge avis très chez mes
enfants que j'emmerde ray et je garderai
leur dos
non mais toutes les doublettes tous les
peuples qui sortent d'une période
économiquement moins faste au sens
classique du pib c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont organisés c'est du reste comme ça
qui était organisée des espagnols c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont beaucoup mieux passé
la crise que nous c'est parce qu'il
avait une cellule familiale qui était
beaucoup plus résiliente
quand vous êtes obligés d'avoir un
deuxième salaire pour payer la crèche
parce qu'il n'est pas le cas des
ingénieurs de l'ouest c'est mais ce qui
est le cas des employés au smic j'en
connais qui ont deux enfants dans le
deuxième salaire n'est pas loin de
servir à payer la crèche bain très bon
moyen de mieux s'en sortir c'est vous
supprimez la crèche
vous faites venir des grands parents qui
même avec une plus petite retraite font
que l'équation globale de la famille
voilà donc faut se coltiner la
belle-mère je suis bien placé pour
savoir ce soit drôle mais non voilà ce
que je suis en train de vous dire est un
problème transversale et systémique
savez disruptif partout partout partout
11 % des émissions sont dues à d'autres
choses le traitement des déchets les
chaînes du froid les déesses de loger
n'est donc je reviens à ce que j'étais
en train de dire le problème est partout
donc pour un problème qui est partout il
faut avoir des vues systémique
il ya quand même une bonne nouvelle dans
cette affaire ce que j'attends de vous
sortir des primaires c'est que la france
cocorico à une tradition historique
d'être particulièrement performante
quand il faut s'attaquer aux problèmes
complexes et à large échelle
c'est notre force historique pour savoir
bien fabriquer des autos voyez les
allemands pour savoir bien vendre voyez
les anglais pour savoir bien concevoir à
la solution à un problème complexe et à
large échelle
voyez les français c'est la raison pour
laquelle les français sont
particulièrement performants dans toutes
les infrastructures de long terme à
large échelle l'énergie les transports
d'édification urbaine etc
on est je vais être un peu prétentieux
les meilleurs on n'est pas toujours le
plus modeste mais on est les meilleurs
objectivement quand vous regardez les
ingénieries performante dans le monde
elles sont trustées par des français je
loue berger les des français systra des
français veolia water des français de
vous à suivre
les françaises jouent le jeu on part
vraiment d'être en scène les français
sont extrêmement performants dans ce
segment là qu'est ce que c'est que le
problème que je viens de vous exposer
c'est un problème
un des véritables monstrueusement
compliqué à large échelle de long terme
sautant dessus nous en tombent dessus
c'est notre salut économique
sautant dessus ça sentait pas le salut
tout le monde
mais ça sera le nôtre sur ton dessus je
suis très sérieux quand je vous dis ça
quoi soit on dit voilà je vais finir
avec ce petit schéma qui résume ce que
je vous ai raconté
nous vivons donc dans un monde dans
lequel 20 de ressources naturelles
gratuites ont été fournis pour notre
plus grand bonheur dont des combustibles
qui brûlent ils vous en fournit les
moteurs et la chine y est donc la
transformation à vitesse accélérée de
tout le reste est donc tous les objets
qui peuplent aujourd'hui notre quotidien
et la structure sociale que nous avons
bâti dessus parce que les machines ont
fourni la productivité du travail la
productivité du travail a fourni les 35
heures les congés payés les retraites
les études longues l'urbanisation la
désertification des campagnes une
bagnole pour tout le monde
les revendications du medef et de la cgt
reilly et les provinces de croissance
perpétuelle et politique à mon avis même
la démocratie je risque cette hypothèse
est un état un fruit de ça c'est quand
même vachement plus simple d'être élu
sur la base de promesses qui vont se
réaliser que sur la base de promesses
qui vont pas se réaliser et si le monde
est infini c'est plus facile de réaliser
des prouesses
donc je pense que ce que nous emmener en
train de vivre aujourd'hui est le fruit
pour l'essentiel de la profusion
énergétique près des terres et la
contrepartie de cette confusion matériel
s'appelle le pays dès qu'on aimerait
tant voir croître notamment parce que
c'est la base fiscale à quelques les
élus n'aiment pas restreindre le budget
public et les deux limites à cette
affaire je vous en ai un tout petit peu
parlé c'est à la fois la question aval
c'est-à-dire le changement climatique et
la question amont c'est à dire le goulet
d'étranglement sur les combustibles
fossiles
je vais finir en vous emmenant aux
médias le problème à bâle il est sur la
table
structurellement c'est à dire que il est
résulte de recherche qui sont faites par
des chercheurs le chercheur il ya
peut-être dans cette salle son métier et
le rendre public ce qu'il sait c'est
comme ça qu on lui crédite c'est comme
ça qu'il est valorisé
c'est comme ça qu'ils progressent c'est
comme ça qu'il est reconnu à tel point
soit dit en passant que les chercheurs
de second qui publie pas grand chose
certains sont tentés par le
climato-scepticisme parce que comme ça
ça leur permet d'être reconnu sur un
autre terrain que celui des médias mais
un chercheur oui c'est un des
déterminants les galas brito sera
déterminant maintenant en ce qui
concerne le temps là ce concept
changement climatique toute
l'information sur la table donc les
médias passent on en parle en ce qui
concerne l'approvisionnement en
combustibles fossiles et plus largement
en ressources minières
toute l'information et propriétés
d'opérateurs commerciaux ou d'opérateurs
étatiques dans des régimes non
démocratiques pour avoir l'info bon
courage donc moi ça m'a pris cinq six
ans peut-être même 10 de commencer à
avoir ce que je crois être un début de
vue un peu étayée sur la question parce
que vous n'avez pas d'autre moyen que de
cuisiner un parent des experts
compétents ou que vous pensez être
compétent sur la question pour voir si à
la fin vous arrivez à dresser un tableau
cohérente tout ce qui vous en raconter
ça vous prend 5 à 10 ans donc ça vous
prend un mois de tout comprendre sur le
changement climatique vous enfermer dans
une pièce ou coupés du monde extérieur
vous pas les chairs rapport du giec qui
fait de mille pages vous arriverez peut
comprendre un peu près tout ce qu'il ya
dedans pas tous exactement mais vous y
arriverez vous sortez de votre mois de
lecture surtout si vous prenez des notes
vous aurez à peu près de contribuer vous
ne pouvez pas faire ça sur les
combustibles fossiles
c'est impossible l'information est
éparpillé pas synthétiser ya pas de
publication et en plus les gens
compliquant ce rush boulbon parce qu'ils
confondent leurs désirs et la réalité
par exemple agence internationale de
l'énergie s'est régulièrement des
scénarios sur la consommation future
c'est la consommation souhaité ils
disent les gens veulent plus de bagnoles
de clairoix plus d'énergie mouais enfin
bon enfin si un peu plus de pétrole qui
sont des paysans n'ont pas plus à donc
et le raisonnement qui et combien de
pétrole va sortir du puits n'est pas
allée yeux parce que pour tenir ce
raisonnement pour acheter des bases de
données d'espionnage industriel très
cher qui va des millions de dollars que
michael ne s'achète pas sauf que j'ai
que collaborateur quelqu'un qui a
travaillé pendant trois ans là ils
pensent avoir à toute équité l'analyste
oil and gas
je pense avoir une petite idée sur la
manière dont ça se pense voilà donc en
conclusion je le redis c'est un problème
systémique c'est un problème dans lequel
il n'y a pas de easy way out au sens de
j'attends tranquillement que les autres
s'occupent du problème pour moi par
contre il ya une opportunité historique
pour nous autres français
je le redis je suis très sérieux quand
je dis ça c'est que c'est un problème
compliqué qui s'invite partout
donc je pense que c'est une opportunité
pour nous bon fêter plus longue habitude
j'ai encore vingt bonnes minutes c'est
l'équipe